[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il dit que bbb bbb mais il est important
c'est suffisant mais c'est suffisant que
raconte la série télévisée soda
l'histoire d'un super-héros qui
attaquent les méchants à coups de
canettes de soda l'histoire d'un
intellectuel du xviie siècle en mal
d'amour et de poésie ou l'histoire d'un
lycéen et de ses potes il
merci à regarder au soda j'étais
président d'un festival dans lequel il y
avait cette sélection de sade à savoir
vous la péter pas non plus les raisons
savez vous ce que ce qu'est instagram
comment in-stat guam on se grille y est
on va partir ce modus inf th et ar am de
tout tu te instagram est ce que c'est
une application pour avoir les règles de
grammaire instantanément une application
permettant de partager des photos ou un
jeu de récré où l'on chante instagram
pic et pic et colégram premier
l'application pouvoir des règles de
grammaire non c'est l'application
permettant de partager les photos qui
est sur instagram et je lai en plus
[Rires]
[Musique]
bon bon pour patrick celle qui perd les
eaux qui jouent à ce jeu est là excuse
moi de répondre c'est patrick vous
attendez d